actually let's make it a three sorry
that's better all right I changed that
two and two or three because as you guys
know with something like say a parabola
you don't need calculus to find where
these stationary points are do you if I
wanted to find out where the mineral
maximum was without differentiation what
would I do
I would look for what it is by
definition the vertex but then that
raises the question how do I find the
vertex you would look at the axis of
symmetry right because a parabola is
symmetrical okay Kimiko's however no
such nice patterns cubic curves are not
symmetrical by and large so therefore
how do we find the stationary points on
such a curve first because we're in
calculus land instinctively what would
you do you should differentiate so let's
do that I can differentiate this and
what do you get okay
I have a derivative 3x squared minus 3
power law looks like it's worked out
just fine okay
now remember I said to you the thing
that all of these stationary points have
in common is that dy/dx equals zero at
those stationary points okay very
important to note D 1 DX obviously isn't
always zero all the time like over here
dy/dx would be negative over here it
would be positive okay so a lot of
people don't write this please please
please do not write this a lot of people
on the next line knowing what they're
trying to do they will simply write this
okay now eventually they'll find the
same answer that you will find
ok except they've kind of committed some
mathematical violence along the way
because that that is the derivative and
the derivative like I was just saying is
clearly not always zero it changes all
the time that's the point of calculus
okay if it didn't change we wouldn't in
to differentiate okay so instead of just
leaping to this line what you should do
is you should add a tiny bit of
connected tissue to say what on earth
you're doing right we're trying to find
stationary points so you would say to
find stationary points
or if you like stationary points exists
when and the next thing I'm gonna say is
let's let the derivative being zero all
right if you want if you're in a higher
you probably can abbreviate stationary
points as SP but I don't like doing it
because when you start having lots of
abbreviations you can't remember which
ones you're allowed to abbreviate and
which ones you're not allowed to
abbreviate and some of them you can't as
you can see when we get to this guy
later on so now that I've done this now
I will go to that line I told you about
three x squared minus three equals zero
tell me what to do I'm going to divide
both sides by three that would be nice
that gives me a very convenient function
okay now what okay I can factorize here
with difference of squares so this is X
minus 1 X plus 1 so now I can say x
equals plus or minus one okay now right
at the top here I said what we're trying
to do is find stationary points are
these points and the answer is no these
are x values of points so I need to go a
little bit further to find out where
exactly these things are along with my x
value I also need a Y value where am I
going to get that Y value from yeah
there's only a single equation here
which just has Y in it like as soon as I
left that I started differentiating so
I've got to go and substitute back in
the original equation okay so I'm what
I'm going to say is when x equals and
I'll just take them one at a time I
usually go from left to right so we'll
start with negative 1 when x equals
negative 1 y equals let's have a look
negative 1 plus 3 plus 7 how's that look
are you happy with that
that sounds like 9 dad all right I've
got a Y value that corresponds to that x
value but I have another X values to
deal with so I'm going to say when x
equals 1 y equals okay let's have a look
one minus three plus five five so I've
got an x value that's matching y another
atte and it's matching y so now I can
conclude I can say therefore there are
stationary points at and then tell me
the coordinates
yep minus 1 comma 9 and 1 comma excuse
me 5 . finished ok so what did we do we
knew we had to use calculus so the first
thing you did was differentiate and then
once you had a derivative you were going
to do something with it in order to find
your stationary points and this is what
you did you let the first derivative be
0 and then the rest of it sort of took
care of itself
just don't forget to substitute at the
end